oh just look at that silhouette you all
know who this is gonna be yeah it's
Batman do I even really need to
explain this it's Batman just
listen to him say it I'm Batman god it's
Batman but okay for the sake of
some integrity I'll go into more detail
first of all let me make it specific
which Batman's I'm talking about seeing
how there are so many of them there's a
lot of good renditions but the ones that
stand out the most to me are probably
the Michael Keaton version and the Kevin
Conroy version these guys are the
definitive Dark Knight's yeah I know
what no Christian Bale those horse
treats us they were trained killers yeah
no but even taking the goofy voice out
of it I still stand by these characters
the most where the Christopher Nolan
version seemed to really like to spell
out what the character was going through
and yet seem to really like to have him
be duped every possible second yeah just
hold that dumb face even more it makes
you look more empowering duh
these two versions definitely show their
weaknesses as well but more often show
their strengths whenever something did
get the best of them they never looked
confused or dumbfounded
do they look determined and quick on
their feet to figure out how to fix it
whatever the case almost nothing seemed
to surprise them and you have to admire
that in a field where you come across
some of the strangest imagery you'll
ever see it's pretty cool that these
guys go in with the understanding of
yeah I was prepared for that and that's
what they pretty much are they're the
people that are never intimidated by
anything or at the very least don't show
that they're intimidated there's
certainly times in both of their story
ARS where they do show their weaknesses
and when they are letting the stress
finally get to them but they do their
best to keep it their problem and not
anybody else's problem
I really respect that Batman has almost
gained this reputation now is the
brooding jerk who just waits in the
shadows and never trusts anybody and
some retellings do I think exploit that
a little too much but these two have it
at the perfect level they will put their
trust in people such as Alfred or Selina
Kyle
or Vicki Vale or Andrea Beaumont or I
don't know there's people out there but
the point is it's still only a distinct
few and they still at least try to make
an effort to battle it themselves before
actually going to someone else to ask
for help and they do it when they
finally know they need help they're not
stubborn they're smart this is a
character that has so many demons to
battle and with these interpretations
you never have a doubt that they won't
be able to battle them but you never
quite know how they're going to do it
you just know they're gonna do it the
right way the way that you can admire
the way that's respectable
the way that has a lot of Honor the way
that's not trying to impress anybody the
way that makes us look up to them the
way that makes Bruce Wayne seem like a
perfectly normal ballast guy never
suspicious are hungry for attention
Batman was the ultimate hero growing up
he represented tragedy at a young age
but an overcoming strength in his later
years with that strength always being
challenged but never being truly
defeated it's a kind of responsibility
I've looked up to as a kid and I still
look up to nowadays the responsibility
to do what is needed whether it's with
help or completely on your own what else
can I say
it's Batman